[Music]
did you see that there's a new black
panther trailer out right and i'm i'm
about to play it but before i play it i
just wanted to show you something
disney
logged into the account
of oh yeah of a dead man
chadwick boseman
to promote a comic book movie bro
so anyway i haven't this this trailer
the other one the game of thrones when i
saw this trailer i haven't seen yet but
i figured we'd check out the new
what's it called wakanda forever
is that the fuji's version what
[Music]
don't shut nothing
[Music]
that's just the puff daddy white party
i'm sorry this is a little
what a little
for marvel movie you know what i mean
like this is a little emotionally
manipulative and yeah
a little gross
look at cisco's there so this movie's
gonna be all about it's gonna be a big
giant chadwick boseman memorial but
they're just gonna try to
right instead of spray painting on the
back of a t-shirt they're making an
entire marvel movie out of it
but they that's basically that's what it
is they just tried it but they're also
gonna try to gross like a billion
dollars off and it will and it will this
movie will oh
this is [ __ ] great it's picking at
the corpse
good friends
and good friends how much do they talk
about him in this movie
well you'll see that
i saw still of like graffiti of him or
something like you know he's a hero i
don't know how he died i guess in the in
the i mean i know how he died in real
life i don't know he died in the movies
i mean i'd still i'd rather people speak
[ __ ] spray painting pictures of
chadwick boozers
at least he gave money to charity and he
was a nice person and everybody that met
him was like what a lovely nice man
exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah they must be out of sandals
doesn't the point when they were going
when they were [ __ ] going in it felt
like the beginning of a sandal right
there sandals commercial
in this great future
you can't forget
is this even no woman no cry of white
cliff isn't screaming something over it
wow
he wanted way more too much money and
they were like yeah let's get a woman to
sing it [ __ ] make it all sad
oh let me guess that's supposed to be
his baby
is that going to be you're drowning that
baby
from the regular
brian ryan coogler
oh this is gonna be bad boy hey
get it on the list yeah we're gonna have
to watch this when it comes out for a
ride yeah ryan cougar this is gonna be
bad
all right
wait
why are they riding whales yeah why are
they why is there so much ocean based i
don't
same thing as the water polo thing no
but i mean like that just
statistically speaking is this a new
avatar movie i don't even know anymore i
know africa is obviously a continent so
it's surrounded by ocean like every
other continent but it's not
known for its ocean stuff and also
for me i would think okay well we use
the lush jungles and we show wakanda and
you know all the beautiful [ __ ]
animals and like the zebras and [ __ ]
that's this the aesthetic right yeah you
this is sort of savannah this is sort of
robbing aquaman yeah our other
intellectual project of sort of
aquaman's dc
is aquaman dc i don't think
that's the deep marvel aquaman yeah yeah
yeah he's not great that's one of the
only
water-based guy was one of the only
things dc beat you on yeah water-based
guy water guys
and honestly batman which when you look
at here superheroes on paper if you were
just to explain them to me in the 1940s
batman's the stupidest one he shouldn't
be as cool
there's no way
let me guess the white colonizers are
coming for wakanda's vibranium
this is avatar it's avatar unobtainium
it's just vibranium it's a different
animal yeah it's avatar when i saw the
suits going down into the wings
it's a different amy it's all that is
[Applause]
and my entire family
is gone
there it is that's the still i saw
but
rave sack says everything finna be all
right infinity all right now have i not
given everything
no
no is that what that i know what this is
from the comics
oh no no no no no no no
no no no no that's iron that's
that's iron heart that's the teenage
black girl that replaces iron man i'll
[ __ ] swear to god
people not people don't know this but a
lot of people blame
disney for making marvel woke and what
people don't realize is before disney
bought marvel marvel in the comics was
already getting woke they were doing
this kind of stuff they're doing like a
bunch of gay superheroes who were doing
black teenager iron man that they were
doing a lot they were just pushing all
this [ __ ] stupid woke [ __ ] into it so
she's gonna build an iron man suit
with a hammer
in a cave like like like robert danny jr
no no but here's the difference scene
the difference was that robert downey jr
in that cave
was able to get anything he needed
because they had him hostage because
they wanted him to build something a
weapon system so he was able to get all
the stuff brought to him right to build
the thing you just tricked them this is
you just
so she's wakandan i guess okay
[Music]
[Applause]
by the way oh we've talked about this
trailer core you know what trailer core
is right
trailer cores when they record a
re-record a famous it's every bro in the
last five years every every movie has
almost every movie has this whether we
re-record a famous song
like slower but just for a movie trailer
right and they do this trailer yeah it's
called trailer corp there's entire
there's hilarious
now that you're pointing it out though
i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah you're right like
this is called trailer core where they
do is they'll take like a nirvana song
and like slow it down with just a piano
and play it over a horror movie or
something and
this is trailer core
[Applause]
you're right because they always said
this
the cinematic stuff to the songs yeah
you're right right it's totally
trailer core that's very funny that
makes total sense to me now there's it's
funny
spitfire more drums and foot stomping
that's maybe they just add a bunch of
the go go one day go down youtube and
just search trailer core this entire
playlist of every movie that has trailer
core music that's [ __ ] hilarious
[Applause]
oh dude
i am so uncomfortable right now
wait a second
well who what maybe i'm wrong and i hope
i am
but that's gonna be the new that's the
new black panther right
is that a female physique
it looks female i don't want i don't
know maybe i'm wrong but
you think it's look at how how small the
wrists are is that a
small calves is the new black panther
going to be a chick
i bet it's going to be a chick
rumors it's been a while that it was
going to be a chick yeah frozen
so i looked it up um
there is a
there is a rein
uh there's a point where black panther
surely becomes black panther so
the girl in this one the
i guess the the the the sister becomes
black panther
oh
have fun
don't do the wakanda i can't do this the
problem is that when the girls when the
girl is black panther those are lee
press-on nails that come out
no i got five people a whole i could
talk i'll just break off the cheap
dollar store yes
cool
not even february cool
i would have been february for black
history month i mean that's just me
though
so you're not excited for it um no i
wasn't excited for the first one that's
fair uh
i remember what a battleground the movie
black panther became yeah
and me and royce were just like
it's not gonna be
good but it's not going to be
particularly bad it'll be meh
and the first one was meh chadwick bosen
pretty good act like it was you know
they made that first one a very faithful
kind of movie this is the problem with
the black panther that i've said and
this is my issue with it because a lot
of people are saying the best movie the
year whatever black panther re-watch it
one day it's a movie
that never feels like it starts
it's a movie where it's it's just set up
setup setup setup setup and you're like
there's no meat to it and then at the
end there's a fight
and i'm like i mean i get it but it felt
empty the problem was was the the the
racial pandering and all the people
going
greatest movie of all time
and then that created and it wasn't the
worst either but but then you had that
you knew it was going to create the
immediate backlash of the people that
were gonna also take on it's gonna be
the worst piece of [ __ ] movie ever made
and you're like
i feel like it's gonna be one of those
below average marvel movies that you
could probably go and see and go
something that if it was on the tv at
the gym you'd watch it on the treadmill
um
yeah it's fine i don't care
it's like the tnt cut of it or something
when we put captions on that's okay i
don't care i just watch it it's for the
fights